michael is with us to start off this
hour in Toledo Ohio hey Michael how are
you I'm good day how are you better than
I deserve what's up alright I just had a
few questions for you me and my wife
were introduced to your program probably
about two or three years ago from a gift
for my mother-in-law and we kind of just
set it off to the side and didn't really
read about it or do anything with it and
I actually just recently discovered the
YouTube channel probably about two
months ago and I watched almost all of
the videos on there and it kind of just
got me fired up I guess and so currently
me and my wife we're looking to start
baby step number one we have a few bills
in collections
credit cards maxed you know typical
typical stuff and we're looking to
really kind of get a jump start on this
and get things figured out but we're not
really sure on where to start um we
don't know if we should pay the
collection bills off first or if we
should save the thousand dollars and
then start the snowball or how we should
go about it um I'm about to graduate
from college to regulate bull what sure
- great you uh computer science and
computer programming good you know what
you have a job lined up uh currently I
do not but I'm actually I've been
looking for maybe about a year now and
just can't get anybody to bite um I'm
still trying to find something or
another but right now I don't have
anything lined up currently I'm a and
cat engineer or draftsman yeah what's
your household income today uh probably
I bring home six hundred forty dollars a
week and so it's like 33 thousand a year
I believe okay she does not work outside
the home no she just a home mom with two
kids ten perfect cool and how old are
you - I am 26 and she is 24 perfect okay
so the program of ours that you set to
the side a few years ago was that a book
or the Financial Peace University kit or
what I believe it was the Financial
Peace University kit because we got the
DVDs and then we have the money makeover
book as well as thanks smart money looks
like somebody loaded you up okay good
yes you did I did okay all right that's
cool
so you've got the stuff to go to the
class I would find a local class in your
area and start attending one night a
week with you and your wife get a
babysitter and go one night a week how
much are the bills that are in
collections um I know we have I think
it's about 250 and hospital bills we
have a thousand dollars in credit card
debt
that's an innocent erections uh not
right now we've been paying minimal how
much is on collections okay probably
about 250 to 300 all right I would just
clear that up immediately you can do
that you can do that out of one month's
budget if you're just real tight on your
budget okay okay and then I would start
your baby steps and baby step one as you
know is to save $1,000 and then baby
step two is we're going to list all the
rest of our debts smallest to largest to
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and attack the little one
and work our way right down you've heard
that before right yeah okay that's the
debt snowball and baby step two
everything but your house you're selling
everything in sight you're having a
garage sale you're working all the extra
hours you can work you're going crazy
you get graduated you're gonna get you
income up and then we're going to
continue on through the process and once
you're debt-free everything but the
house then we're going to take you to
baby step three and you know what that
is three to six months of expenses but
what happens is when you get a group
when the reason I'm telling you to join
a class and not just watch the DVDs is
you get the experience of being around
people that are doing the same thing
you're doing and you get a positive peer
pressure and it really helps you with
the encouragement because you're going
to be sacrificing rather deeply to start
making some progress here and you need
to keep you need people whispering in
your ear that you're not crazy
because it's going to feel pretty crazy
because you're not you're not making a
ton of money right now and now you know
you don't have a lot of room to cut and
so as your income goes up with your
graduation hopefully
you know you're going to start making
more and more and more may double it you
very well could yeah you know you're
gonna be able to clear some stuff really
fast and actually our house payment
right now is 580 a month on a 20 year
loan yeah that's our we were trying to
we're trying to aim for 15 but we just
kind of got it's just before I knew
anything you were preaching and I would
just I would just sit tight on that okay
and then we have a Tahoe that we owe
about 13 on and um it's worth about 18
and you know I'm kind of you know I
really want to keep the car but I'm
trying to debate you know whether we can
afford it I mean right now we can afford
it if we budget stick to the budget not
really to work out not really you really
can't afford it today but by this time
next year you very well could because
again your income could have doubled if
I thought your income was going to stay
at 33 I would sell it
but I don't think that's the case I
think you're in a good field that you've
studied here and I don't know when your
income will double but I predict in the
next 24 months it's going to and so if
you guys want to struggle and fight to
keep that toe and get it paid off that's
not the end of the world to me that's
not a deal breaker
it wouldn't hurt anything to sell it and
drive a paid four or five thousand
dollar car it sure would get the
pressure off your household right now be
nice and then in a year or two buy
another car and move up in car you know
with cash later that wouldn't make me
mad either it just depends on how you
want to live how hard you want to fight
how much other stuff you want to cut so
you keep that beast you know okay but
I'm amputating the Tahoe is not a bad
plan and again if I thought your income
is gonna stay where it is an $18,000 car
on a 33 thousand our income is ludicrous
but it's not that but it's not ludicrous
in a $70,000 income and again I really
do think you're heading that way so I
just don't know how quickly so you guys
can judge that and what I do start the
fight without selling the car but if you
start getting a little bit tired while
you're fighting in April hasn't gotten
here yet and you hadn't gotten the new
job yet you always have the option of
amputating the Tahoe and buying a car
with cash for the difference right yeah
you can always go to that estate as step
to it phase 2 of your plan not
step2 we've got baby steps I don't want
to confuse you but phase two of your
plan could be to do that as a relief
valve if you can't can't you know bear
up under the stress of extra hours and
no life and all those things that you're
going to have between now and really
about this time next year okay and but
again I'm anticipating in the summer
time your income going up dramatically
sometime around there and if it doesn't
then you're going to really need to let
go of this car because it's it's not it
doesn't make sense with your current
numbers it does with your future numbers
but I'd go to class dude you own the kit
and I go in there they'll get you an
updated kit if you need to do an update
but get the experience of being around
other people that are walking through
this and that's why Financial Peace
University the class at a local church
near you folks is so powerful the
behavior change is so positive because
you're around other people that are
helping you do this thing you're trying
to do to win you got a bunch of
cheerleaders in your corner and you need
that this hard y'all getting out that's
hard nobody said it was easy all we said
was it's worth it this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show